MARK MIRCHANDANI: All right.
Just set it down
right over there.
Yeah.
ANTHONY BUSHONG: I'm exhausted.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: You said it.
Building all of these
applications is tough work.
I don't know what
I'm going to do
when they need to be stateful.
ANTHONY BUSHONG: You know,
Kubernetes on Google Cloud
Platform is a great way to
host stateful applications
with high availability.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: That would
save me a ton of headaches.
ANTHONY BUSHONG: Sounds great.
Let's jump in to a demo
and show you how quickly
we can get this all set up.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Let's start with an
application running
on GKE that requires state.
A simple example would be the
popular blogging platform,
WordPress.
So this is our
WordPress architecture
as represented by
Kubernetes Objects.
We have two key pods--
the WordPress pod,
which runs a WordPress
container, and
MariaDB pod, which
runs the backend database.
Both of these pods
are controlled
by deployments and replica
sets which can be scaled up.
Kubernetes services
give us a stable method
of accessing these pods no
matter the count of replicas.
The MariaDB pod is fronted by an
internal service, type cluster
IP, while the WordPress
pods are exposed
to the public via an external
service type load balancer.
This is where we want
to focus our demo today.
Both of these pods
require state.
WordPress needs to store assets
in its file system and MariaDB
stores post and user data.
So we have a storage
class that defines
the type of persistent volume
that each pod will get.
In our case here, we will
want to create a storage
class for the regional
persistent disk.
Each pod will then have
a persistent volume
claim for their respective
persistent volumes.
Now let's take a look
at how the world worked
before regional persistent
disks were available.
Let's start with a
single zone GKE cluster.
In this case, we have
GCE persistent disks
scoped to a single zone
mounted to the nodes
where our pods are running.
If there's any level of
failure on these nodes,
we're fortunate to have
Kubernetes Self-Healing kick
in.
These pods will migrate to
healthy available nodes,
and the disk, due to
persistent volume claims,
will be able to migrate to
the new nodes, retaining
state for our pods.
All is well.
But this isn't everyone's setup.
More and more, we're
looking for reliability
in our applications,
which means we
want to spread across
multiple failure domains.
So in GKE, customers are
adopting regional clusters,
which means that control
plane is replicated
across multiple zones, as are
the nodes that the applications
run on.
In this demo, we will
have nodes running
in us-west1-b and us-west1-c.
With the persistent
disk scoped to a zone,
we'll run into issues to get
the high availability we desire.
If there is a
zonal failure, pods
will continue to migrate
to a different zone
with healthy nodes.
But, because the persistent
disk is scoped to a single zone,
the state cannot follow.
Enter regional persistent disks.
In the same scenario, we
can now migrate the state
to a different zone as it was
being synchronously replicated
by the regional PDs.
Let's jump into the demo
and see it in action.
So here is our regional Google
Kubernetes Engine cluster.
It's running in us-west1,
with nodes in zones b and c.
Let's use Kube Control
to actually look
at the pods, deployments,
and service objects
that comprise our
WordPress application.
So as you can see, we have
one of each pod for WordPress
and MariaDB, and we also have
an external load balancer
fronting the WordPress pod.
So if we actually throw
that into the browser,
we'll see our WordPress blog,
and it's titled, "Hello Take5."
We'll see that if we dive
into the blog section,
we actually have one blog post
titled, "Nice Blog, Take5."
And so we can see that
our state is actually
stored on the persistent
volumes mounted to the MariaDB
and the WordPress pods.
And we can actually use
Kube Control to look
at those objects as well.
So we'll look at the persistent
volumes, the persistent volume
claims, and the specific
storage class that defines
the regional persistent disk.
So we can see that our
claims actually represent
bounded persistent volumes.
And if we actually dive into
and describe our storage class,
we'll see that we've
created a very specific type
for regional persistent disk.
We'll see here, defined
in the parameters,
that we have replication,
type regional persistent disk.
We'll see that it's a
persistent disk standard.
And it's running
in zones, or it's
replicated across the zones
us-west1-b and us-west1-c.
So now, we will want to see
the high availability in action
with regional PDs by
simulating a zonal failure.
This script, titled
"Big Red Button,"
has a command at the end
that will actually take out
one of the zones
where my nodes are
running for this GKE cluster.
So once I execute that
script, the script
will actually identify
where both the MariaDB
and the WordPress
pods are running.
So now we see the actual node
that the pod is running on,
and we see that that node
is located in us-west1-b.
And so we are now going
to simulate that failure
in us-west1-b, and we will have
to answer yes to that prompt.
And now we will perform a watch
to see what actually happens
with our pods when they are
moved into the node running
in us-west1-c.
OK?
And now we've actually sped
through the zonal failure
to see that our pods
have successfully
rescheduled from the
node in us-west1-b
to the node in us-west1-c.
Now, to see if state actually
followed into the new zone,
let's jump into
our WordPress blog.
So if we refresh the
page, we actually
see that our blog is still
there with the same title.
And let's look at
that blog post.
"Nice Blog, Take5"
is still present,
and nothing has
changed about it.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Great.
So we can see how easy it
is to use Google Kubernetes
Engine to host stateful,
highly available applications.
ANTHONY BUSHONG: Absolutely.
Don't forget to like,
comment, and subscribe.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: And if you'd
like to get in contact with us,
click on the link
in the description.
[MUSIC PLAYING]